um
oh
bruh
today
uh
folks thank you very much for being here
i'm about to sign an executive order but
i want to begin by
thanking the vice president for helping
this but also thank
chairman milley who has
been a great great help
and also the
soon-to-be uh secretary of defense so
when we can finish this will be sworn in
in a moment and so don't say anything to
cause him to change his mind okay
um but all can you decide this is uh
reinstating a position that uh
previous commanders and uh
as well as the
secretaries have supported and what i'm
doing is enabling all qualified
americans to serve their country
in uniform and essentially uh
uh re restoring the situation you
guessed before with
transgender personnel if qualified in
every other way
can serve their government in the united
states military
so that's about to sign and i'm going to
get a chance i'm told
a little later on another matter later
this afternoon when i
speak to another order to answer all of
your questions on a whole range of
things but i'm going to be
going to the swearing you shortly after
this okay thank you again
all right thank you thank you guys
now it's a long way to come out
come on let's move let's go please
now we gotta go here
oh
very good
um
oh maybe
i think
what
thank you i'll be here all week think
that that's the queue for me to go back
out there
come on i like kabob evans
okay
thanks yeah you're good
is
what is coming out of your eye at the
moment
are you able to send something down the
line
thank you
recycling
um
you
it still shows back
girl
today
yes i do
okay
i knew yeah
by yourself
being pretty um
hello
um
um
you hear me
hey
okay
okay
thank you
thank you
so
wait what's that yeah
oh i haven't gotten it
okay let me give you my test one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
how about now jeff bennett microphone
okay same one okay
okay
john president trump also talks about
the why the emperor he emphasized
buying american products but five is
going to tweak the policy with an
executive order of his own and just few
minutes ago in the oval office
we saw him sign a reversal of the
pentagon policy
that banned transgender service members
client's pledge as a candidate was to
repair relationships with allies and his
very first foreign leader call was with
canada's prime minister justin trudeau
who ended with some bad news our
neighbors to the north are upset
by full flood on the permit from the
keystone xl type language canada was
hoping to keep going
so the white house tells us this about
that call the president
acknowledged prime minister trudeau's
disappointment regarding the decision to
rescind
the permit for the keystone xl pipeline
and reaffirmed his commitment
to maintain an active bilateral dialogue
and to further deepen cooperation
with canada and remember uh last week on
his way out president trump
trying to lift covet-related travel
restrictions on people coming
into this country from the uk to eu and
brazil
there's close that he lifted tomorrow
but the blind administration is
pointing out that job is now president
they don't want that so
they're going to keep those restrictions
in place and they're signaling they
might actually strengthen them
we'd like to hear more from the press
secretary john saki in about
10 minutes
thanks alex thanks can you see 115
for the uh
oh that should be
whatever
okay
position
so
hey
yeah yeah
so do you want to do one last check with
me
yeah sure
thank you very much
what's up what's up
yes
alright
hmm
let's go
so
okay
two-minute warning for the briefing
two-minute warning thank you
is
okay
so
huh
hi everyone hello
good afternoon happy monday to everyone
a couple of announcements at the top
first as a part of this administration's
accessibility and inclusion efforts
starting today we will have an asl and
american sign language
interpreter for our daily press
briefings today's interpreter heather
is joining us virtually the president is
committed to building an america that is
more inclusive more just and more
accessible for every american
including americans with disabilities
and their families
next i wanted to share a few updates
from the covid response team
first today the president will sign a
presidential proclamation to reduce the
spread of coven 19 through travel
especially as we see faster spreading
variants emerging across the world
this proclamation is part of the biden
administration's whole of government
decisive and science-driven response
to the covid19 pandemic a particular
note
on advice of our administration's
medical and coveted team
president biden has decided to maintain
the restrictions previously in place
for the european chengen area the united
kingdom
republican republic of ireland and
brazil
with the pandemic worsening and more
contagious variant
contagious variants spreading this isn't
the time to be lifting restrictions on
international travel
and in light of the contagious variant
uh b1351
south africa has been added to the
restricted list
additionally beginning tomorrow
international travelers to the united
states
must provide proof of a negative test
within three days of travel
to airlines prior to departure the
president is taking these steps
on the advice of his covit 19 and
medical team
and we're already working as a real
partner to the states to address their
needs to vaccinate the public
this weekend west virginia asked the
biden administration for assistance at
an understaffed vaccine distribution
center
at the president's direction fema was
deployed to help support the vaccination
site
this comes as part of the president's
order last week that directs fema
to stand up vaccination centers and
support states vaccination efforts
we look forward to continuing to be the
partners for states
moving forward last on the covid uh
last update on okovid i wanted to
briefly preview the first of our
public health briefings which will begin
this wednesday and will be done
regularly
uh procedures will be science-led
briefings featuring our public health
officials and members of our covid19
response team these briefings will
typically happen
three times a week to provide the
american people with key updates
on the virus and our government's
response the reflection of our
commitment to being transparent and
honest with the public
about the pandemic and the work our
whole of government team is doing every
day and you all be able to participate
within those of course as well
finally i think finally this morning
president biden issued an executive
order setting the policy that all
americans
who are qualified to serve in the armed
forces of the united states
should be able to serve today's action
revokes the presidential memorandum
of march 2013 2018 and also confirms the
revocation
of the presidential memorandum of august
25th of 2017.
today's action fills another campaign
promise
with this eo no one will be separated or
discharged from the military or denied
reenlistment on the basis of gender
identity
and for those transgender service
members who were discharged or separated
because of their gender identity
their cases will be re-examined
president biden believes that gender
identity should not be a bar to military
service
and that america's strength is found in
its diversity america is stronger at
home and around the world
when it is inclusive uh last thing sorry
i said it was the last but
lot going on here uh this afternoon the
president will sign an executive order
that takes an important step to support
american manufacturing
with the spy american executive order
the president is already making good on
his commitment
to building a future that is made in
america by all of america's workers
through the buy american executive order
the president will put to work
the nearly 600 billion dollars in
taxpayer dollars
that goes toward federal contracting in
support of american
manufacturing and good paying jobs for
america's workers
the eo directs agencies to close
loopholes in how made in america
products are measured so that we can
close loopholes and ensure
increase the amount of a product that
must be made in the us for it to qualify
under by american law he will also
appoint a senior white house official to
oversee this policy to ensure it's
actually enforced
and that all agencies are seeking small
and medium-sized american businesses to
make the products they need
the eo will also tighten and make public
the waiver process so that american
workers
and manufacturers can see how federal
dollars are spent
and where they're going so i will stop
there and john is going to kick us off
uh thank you jen uh we know you have to
leave at two o'clock so we'll just get
started right now two topics for you
please uh
one foreign and one domestic uh overseas
uh first
over the weekend there were dozens of
significant protests in russian cities
over the arrests of alexander which were
put down harshly by police there
what sort of u.s response is being
considered what sort of actions or
sanctions could occur
and when does the president plan to
speak to president putin
first i'd like to point all of you to a
statement that was
released this weekend by the state
department strongly condemning
the use of harsh tactics against
protesters and journalists
in cities throughout russia these
continued efforts to suppress
russians rights to peacefully protest
and assemble
and expand their freedom of expression
and the
arrest of opposition figure alexey
navalny
and the crackdown on protests that
followed are troubling indications of
further restrictions on russian
civil society so i'll just reiterate our
call
from here on russian authorities to
release all those detained for
exercising their universal rights
and for the immediate and unconditional
release of alexei navalny
we also urge russia to fully cooperate
with the international community's
investigation into
the poisoning of lexi navalny and
credibly explain the use of a chemical
weapon
on its soil and last week we announced
uh that the president issued a tasking
to the intelligence community
for its full assessment of a range of
activities including of course the
solar wind cyber breach russian
interference in the 2020 election
its use of chemical weapons against
alexia navalny and the alleged bounties
on u.s soldiers in afghanistan
that is ongoing um that review is a
100-day review
so we'll have an update on that uh when
it concludes actually let me
i apologize i may have misstated that
it's not i don't have a timeline for the
timeline of the review it's something
that's ongoing there's it's a priority
of course
has it called the schedule with
president i don't have any calls to
predict for you uh at this point
uh but obviously the president is
picking up the phone engaging with a
range of
foreign leaders europeans and others uh
there's more planned in the next couple
days and we'll have readouts as those
occur
and wanna hear at home the president has
repeatedly stressed the urgency of the
covert relief package the need to get
something done
now with that in mind in considering the
reaction of republican lawmakers to
outreach that was done over the weekend
should there be a more narrow focus on
the virus and vaccine that could be done
sooner and while we know that these
white house officials have talked to the
hill
can you please speak to the president's
personal involvement who has he spoken
to
the president has been personally
engaging and engaging with democrats and
republicans
we're not going to read out all those
calls for you because those are private
conversations
and we feel that's the most effective
way to get
this package moving forward as you know
there was
a call that occurred yesterday that we
did a brief readout
on from that call part of our ongoing
engagement to talk with democrats and
republicans and
i'll convey that this is how in the
president's view and we talked about
this this morning this process should
work he puts
his policy forward his vision forward
and then democrats and republicans can
engage and give their input and feedback
on what they think is going to work and
how to move this package forward
so in our view this is working exactly
as it should work
and but in terms of the is there concern
democrats themselves
senator sanders has an independent of
course and speaker pelosi has suggested
the reconciliation should be considered
now the time is wasting there isn't
time for this sort of legislative back
and forth well the president himself has
conveyed the urgency
of moving this package forward and
that's certainly something he has also
conveyed
privately to democrats and republicans
and it's not just him there's
urgency to the american people for this
package to move forward
because we are going to hit a cliff an
unemployment cliff
unemployment insurance cliff i should
say in march where millions of people
won't be able to have access to
unemployment insurance
we're going to hit a point where we
won't have enough funding for vaccine
distribution
nobody wants to have the conversation no
member of congress
in may or june uh when there we don't
have the funding to put back
to reopen schools i should say so
there's an urgency he's conveyed
i will say as it relates to
reconciliation uh just to take a step
back everybody watching is not as in the
weeds on the senate process as all of
you so let me just take a moment to
explain
reconciliation is a mean means of
getting a bill passed
there are a number of means of getting
bills passed uh that does not mean
regardless of how the bill is passed
that democrats and republicans cannot
both vote for it
so uh the president obviously wants to
make this bipartisan hence he's engaging
with members of both parties and
he remains committed to that moving
forward go ahead caitlyn just real quick
you were talking about the clip in march
does he think it will get passed by
march
well there's an urgency to moving it
forward and uh he certainly believes it
needs to be
there needs to be progress in the next
couple of weeks he thinks by march it
could get passed
well i i don't want to give a deadline
on it caitlyn but i think
we are all mindful and looking at that
timeline in march
as to when we will hit the unemployment
cliff and it's
it's vital to get things done quickly
and rapidly as quickly as possible
so you said last week he wants it to be
bipartisan of course we've already seen
the republicans pushing back
on the price tag the 15 minimum wage and
who is qualifying for these stimulus
checks
so is he willing to come down on any of
that
well i'm not going to negotiate from
here not that you're expecting me
necessarily to do that but
again the president feels this is
working as it should he proposed his
package
he's getting feedback we're having
conversations we don't expect the final
bill to look
exactly the same as the first bill he
proposed
i will remind you though that the the
bipartisan package that passed in
december
had the same thresholds for the checks
150 000
uh about approximately that amount for
families about 75 000
for individuals in terms of who would
have access to that
uh those checks um and each component of
this package
is vital to get us through this period
of time so that's how the president
looks at the package that each of them
are are essential
not just vaccine distribution money but
funding to ensure that
people can make sure they are putting
food on the table
that their kids are eating that they can
get that they have the bridge needed
to get to the other side of the pandemic
okay and then just quickly yesterday the
cdc director said she could not say how
much vaccine
there was left to go out i i know it's
complicated what's being shipped and
distributed and actually injected but
is there at least a ballpark amount that
officials are aware of
how much vaccine there is well our team
is working right now we've been here for
five days to evaluate the supply so that
we can release the maximum amount while
also ensuring that everyone
can get the second dose on the fda
recommended schedule
so the confusion around this issue which
we acknowledge there is some confusion
is speaks to a larger problem which is
what we're inheriting from the prior
administration
which is much worse than we could have
imagined so we are assessing now
um what we have access to and ensuring
that we have
more of a rapid engagement with states
so that they have more of a heads up on
what to expect in the weeks ahead
to button this up gus perna still works
here right and he's in charge of the
logistics so could he
say how much vaccine there is since
they're in charge of where it's going
well again there is a new cdc director
in charge hence who spoke to this and i
think
what we're trying to do now is fully
assess what we have access to
uh what the status of uh the vaccine
supply looks like and ensure that we're
communicating that accurately and
effectively with the public
good thanks john
confusion around the the lack of uh
clarity about the
vaccine availability um give us a sense
of just how stunning that revelation is
what was president biden's reaction to
learning that
well i i will say having set in a lot of
meetings with president biden about
kovid and his efforts to get the
pandemic under control he asks
a lot of detailed questions about the
status
of supply the status of distribution the
status of
states when there's reporting from all
of you on uh states not having the
information they need
those are specific issues he raises uh
we
we're eyes wide open all of us including
the president uh with the
the knowledge that we were not walking
into a circumstance
where there was going to be a concrete
uh assessment or plan
presented to us when we walked in and
there wasn't uh that's why he put
forward his 200-page vaccine
distribution plan last week and that's
why he hired an experienced and talented
team to
get to the bottom of exactly what we're
looking at uh
so that we can have that assessment
moving forward when does the
administration expect to have a better
sense of the available inventory
well as i noted at the top we're going
to be doing regular briefings
uh three times a week we'll start those
on wednesday
i don't know what assessment they'll
have by wednesday but what our objective
is is to be providing
clear and accurate information to the
public and what's the the white house's
message to
democrats to president biden's
supporters who take him at his word and
say
as it relates to covert relief we are in
a national emergency and we should act
like it
and they want action now they don't want
any sort of delay and they don't want to
experience the opportunity costs that
might come from a delay
in waiting for republicans to get on
board what do you mean with the covet
package
well he he agrees he doesn't want there
to be delay either and
i would note that 70 percent of the
public agrees with what you just said
according to the ipsos poll this weekend
that the the components of this package
the funding for vaccine distribution but
also funding to ensure people can apply
for unemployment insurance
put food on the table money to reopen
schools the public
supports that and we anticipate that the
public will be conveying to
uh the leaders who were elected to
represent them exactly that
go ahead let me just ask you to clarify
the travel requirement of the testing
requirement that applies to
all people boarding planes in the u.s
including u.s citizens
anyone getting on a plane needs a test
from from overseas
yes yes okay i also want to ask a couple
of things
that the trump administration did in the
final stages and i'm wondering whether
you folks are going to intervene
one is that they issued a license to an
israeli billionaire named dan
gertler to allow him to access u.s
financial system that licenses in place
through the end of january 2022. will
the biden administration intervene at
all or does that stand
another one is that he began began uh
the de-listing
or issued an executive order that
triggered the listing of several chinese
companies
in particular three telecoms have sought
a review of that
do you plan on tweaking or rescinding
that order in other words stopping
the de-listing process for these three
chinese telecoms
on the first question unfortunately
we're about to have a treasury secretary
confirmed and i'd send you to them
to speak to any reviews they may
overtake and those sanctions
undertake i should say in those uh in
that sanctions review
um and then on the chinese uh i know
there was some reporting perhaps from
your outlet of course this morning
on that particular uh issue uh as you as
we've noted in here previously uh
we there are a number of reviews complex
reviews interagency reviews i should say
that we're going to undertake
um as it relates to um
a range of our um sorry let me start
again here
a range of regulatory actions and a
range of um
relationships uh with uh companies as it
relates to
to chinese investment and other issues
as well
uh those complex reviews are just
starting and
as i as i noted they will need to go
through the interagency so
the state department the treasury
department a number of others who will
review how we move forward uh we're
we're starting from a a
an approach of patience as it relates to
our relationship with china
so that means uh we're going to have
consultations with our allies we're
going to have consultations with
democrats and republicans and we're
going to allow
the interagency process to work its way
through to review and assess how we
should move forward with our
relationship
possible that those reviews could lead
to a change in this delisting
process down the road well i don't want
to get ahead of any review
but certainly we're taking an
overarching look um
at um all of our all of it and i
i'll as we have more to report we'll
report back to you finally can i just
ask broadly what the president believes
president trump's legacy is with regards
to china in particular around the
tariffs
he imposed the president biden like
those tariffs they remain
in place on quite a large sum of
chinese goods is that under review at
all or are those appropriate at this
time
well as as is as is the case
um with other areas of our relationship
with uh china
um he will uh take a multi-lateral
approach to engaging with china
and that includes evaluating the tariffs
currently in place
and he wants to ensure that we take any
steps
in coordination with our allies and
partners and with democrats and
republicans in congress
as well so nothing to report at this
point in time but
we're committed to the president is
committed to stopping china's economic
abuses on many fronts
and the most effective way to do that is
through working concert with our allies
and partners to do exactly that
go ahead i wanted to follow up a little
bit on some of the china issues
i know that there was an executive order
requiring the sale of tick tocks u.s
business and i wondered if there were
plans to
revoke it or enforce it or what is the
current thinking on that matter
it's a great question i haven't had the
opportunity to speak with our national
security team about it happy to take it
and see if we can get to you more
something more specific go ahead thank
you so much um two questions for you
um the first is sort of stepping back
for a minute at what the
administration's
um goals are unity is something that
president biden spoke about quite a bit
on the campaign trail
to talk about it during the transition
could you talk a little bit more
specifically
about what unity will mean to this
administration whether there are
any kind of benchmarks that you were if
you've identified
um to show that unity has been achieved
and i just started to contrast with the
you know the chronovirus task force of
course you've got very detailed
um you know benchmarks about what that
you know what
you want to achieve sort of moment by
moment but with unity are you talking
about bipartisanship
are you talking about something that's
widely popular in the united states can
you sort of go through what biden is
thinking about
when he says that he wants to achieve
unity sure well
the president came in uh to lead the
country obviously at a time
of great division where there was a
great need for healing
in his view and he spoke about that in
his uh inaugural address just last week
so unity to him
means of course approaching our work
on legislative issues through a
bipartisan lens working with democrats
and republicans
trying to find a path forward on how we
can work together to address the
problems the american people are facing
that's part of it but it also means
projecting that he is going to govern
for all people and address
all the issues that the american people
are facing so for example
that means talking about how the kovid
pandemic impacts not just democrats but
republicans not just blue states but red
states
ensuring that he is reaching out to
democratic and republican governors
democratic and republican mayors
and conveying and every opportunity he
has
that this is a problem that we're all
facing together so
i i think it's a little bit different uh
than than how you can mark
of course uh achieving 100 million shots
in the arms
of americans in the first hundred days
but unity is about the country feeling
that they're in it together and i think
we'll know that when we see it but he's
going to be
working on that and committed to that
every opportunity has to speak to the
public
i just want another question um the
trump administration
the vice the obama administration
initially had wanted to
put harriet tubman on the 20 bill
um the trump administration draws their
feet on that
i wanted to see if the biden
administration has a
sort of view of the timeline on whether
or not she should be
on the paper currency i was here when we
when we announced that and it was very
exciting it hasn't moved forward yet
which we would have been surprised to
learn at the time
the treasury department is taking steps
to resume efforts to put harriet tubman
on the front of the
new 20 notes uh it's important
uh that our notes are our money
of people don't know what a note is uh
reflect the history and diversity of our
country
and harriet tubman's image gracing the
new 20 note would
certainly reflect that so we're
exploring ways to speed up that effort
but
any specifics would of course come from
the department of treasury
um go ahead another one on china china's
xi jinping spoke earlier today i'm
wondering if there's any official white
house reaction to
his comments he talked about unity as
well uh and also talked about
cooperation on coronavirus and other
issues is that like is that kind of
uh statement today likely to uh change
or affect the stance that the us that
the administration has toward china on
on trade and technology no uh
i think our approach to china remains
what it has
been since uh for the last months if not
longer
um we're in a serious competition with
china
strategic competition with china's
defining feature of the 21st century
china is engaged in conduct that it
hurts american workers blocks our
technological edge and threatens our
alliances and our influence in
international
organizations what we've seen over the
last few years is that china is growing
more authoritarian at home and more
assertive abroad
and beijing is now challenging our
security prosperity and values in
significant ways that require
a new u.s approach and this is one of
the reasons as we were talking about a
little bit earlier that
we want to approach this with some
strategic patients and we want to
conduct reviews internally through our
interagency even though i stumbled over
that i needed a little caught more
coffee before i came out here i guess
uh we wanted to engage more uh with
republicans and democrats
uh in congress to discuss the pathway
and most importantly we want to discuss
this with our allies so know that
comments don't
uh change anything we believe that
this moment requires um
a a strategic and a new approach forward
go ahead oh so go ahead hopefully if i
answer your questions now i'm sorry
we'll
we'll go to you now i'll i was going to
pile on a little more on china while
we're on this topic but um
i wondered huawei's been on the entity
list for like two years now
um just before the trump administration
left office they
initiated a new policy to basically
revoke and issue intents to deny
licenses for even
more innocuous items that u.s companies
were selling to huawei
does the the biden administration plan
to keep huawei on the entity list
and continue to enforce this much more
stringent blanket
ban on u.s goods sales china
well technology as i just noted is of
course at the center of the u.s china
competition
china has been willing to do whatever it
takes to gain a technological advantage
stealing intellectual property engaging
in industry on espionage espionage
and forcing technology transfer our view
the president's view is we need to play
a better defense which must include
holding china accountable
for its unfair illegal practices and
making sure that american technologies
aren't facilitating china's military
buildup
so he's firmly committed to making sure
that chinese companies cannot
misappropriate and misuse american data
and we need a comprehensive strategy as
i've said uh and a more systematic
approach that actually addresses the
full range of these issues
so there is again an ongoing uh review
of a range of um these issues we want to
look at them carefully
and will be committed uh to approaching
them through the lens of ensuring we're
protecting us data and america's
technological edge
i don't have more for you on it um as we
do we're happy to share that with all of
you go ahead uh president biden
now president biden condemned protests
and violence on the far left in the far
right before
he was president why haven't we heard
anything directly from him
about the riots in portland and the
pacific northwest
since he was inaugurated well he's
taking questions later this afternoon so
perhaps you will i will say from here
that
president biden condemns violence and
any violence in the strongest possible
terms
peaceful protests are a cornerstone of
our democracy
uh but smashing windows is not
protesting and neither is looting
and actions like these are totally
unacceptable and anyone who committed a
crime should be prosecuted to the
fullest extent our team is of course
monitoring it very closely and as he
pushes for
federal help to businesses affected by
covenants and we expect to see
any kind of federal assistance for these
businesses up there that are affected by
cobit and riots well
again i think you know his because we've
we've had this conversation in here
already a few times since i
joined the the team that um his focus is
on
uh getting the american people through
this period of time
and pushing forward on a relief package
that will get them the assistance they
need as it relates to the pandemic and
the impact
of the pandemic so i don't have anything
more for you on that
just one more about the announcement you
made off the top about the travel
restrictions
when president trump was imposing travel
restrictions in march specifically
on china then candidate biden
called it xenophobic and fear-mongering
so
now president biden is putting travel
restrictions on
people coming in from other countries
what words we use to describe max
well i don't think that's quite a fair
articulation uh the president
has been clear that he felt the muslim
ban was xenophobic he overturned the
muslim ban
uh he also though has uh supported um
and he himself even before or we did i
should say even before he was
inaugurated
steps uh travel restrictions in order to
keep the american people safe
uh to ensure that we are getting the
pandemic under control that's been part
of his policy
but he was critical of the former
president for having a policy that was
not more comprehensive than travel
restrictions
and he conveyed at the time and more
recently
the importance of having a multi-faceted
approach math squaring vaccine
distribution
funding in order to get 100 million
shots in the arms of americans in the
first hundred days not just travel
restrictions
go ahead and bath yes uh two questions
one domestic
one foreign uh please the first is
uh the bill pressgrail a congressman
from new jersey just about an hour ago
suggested
firing the entire postal board of
governors and he sent a letter
to the president to that effect is there
any plans to make
changes given what happened at the post
office over the last couple of years
to try and remove the postmaster general
uh it's an interesting question we all
love the mailman and mail woman
i don't have anything for you on it i'm
happy to check with our team on it and
see if
we have any specifics i'm not aware of
anything but uh
we'll circle back with you and then uh
foreign policy question it's my
understanding that the
uh the previous administration did not
release the war powers act resolution
report uh before they left office
is there any plans for uh i know there's
a new secretary of defense
as of as a few out well i guess friday
but
ceremonially today um is there any plan
to either release
the uh the trump administration
letter on the troop levels in various
countries overseas
or to update that more quickly than
might be required by the statute
it's an excellent question i i would
send you to the department of defense
and
my old friend john kirby who i'm sure
would be happy to answer your question
uh go ahead in the back with the
excellent mask on i can
tell flamingos flamingos
all right we're getting creative with
masks i like it
after one year um so just back to russia
given the many unsolved deaths over the
years
of president putin's opponents or near
deaths in the case of navalny
would president biden be holding
president putin personally
accountable for the continued health of
navalny while he's in prison
one other thing which is different but
related what's the position of this
administration on paul whelan
because his family and some of his
supporters
said basically the previous
administration just you know forgot
about it
what's going on with paul and what's
your position
well um let me take the second question
and talk to our national security team
and get you something more comprehensive
um uh and certainly we don't plan to
follow the same pattern of the last
administration uh but
uh on the first question i would say
this is the reason
why uh the president tasked his national
security team his intelligence team
with assessing a range of issues as it
relates to our relationship with
russia including the solar winds breach
including the poisoning of alexi navalny
which we have been quite outspoken about
aren't from our national security
advisor to the state department will
continue to be
we want to see that review conclude but
as has always been the case the
president reserves the right to respond
in the time and manner of his choosing
and i'm not going to take
options off the table from here go ahead
hi
i'm the print pooler today so if
possible can i ask a question also on
the behalf of one of my colleagues who
couldn't be here sure
okay so i'll start with my question um
new york city mayor
bill de blasio announced today that the
city is delaying the opening of
of large copen 19 vaccination sites at
yankee stadium at city fields
governor cuomo has said the state has
the capacity to vaccinate up to 100 000
folks a day
if there was supply as the
administration is
you know analyzing and reconfiguring its
distribution plan
how heavily is um infrastructure
uh being weighed in other words does new
york get first dibs because it has the
capacity to do this right away
um and then the second question would be
on kind of on the same coveted note
um there are seniors who don't have
access to
uh websites don't have folks vouching
for them is there anything the uh
administration is doing to ensure that
seniors uh
who don't have you know anybody to
assist them with scheduling these
appointments that they don't fall
through the cracks
and then i have a second question from
another reporter sure so
on the first question this is a really
important one infrastructure is pivotal
it's not just about the science
scientists medical experts
they've what they've done over the last
year in moving this vaccine forward
has been a herculean effort but now it
is about
ensuring that there are more vaccinators
and there are more places to actually
distribute the vaccine and clearly case
scenarios where there are
large facilities whether they're
football fields or others to do that can
be quite efficient
um there are other places around the
country where
we are seeing developments along those
fronts and we're certainly encouraging
that
but this is a multi-faceted challenge
it's not just about having supply which
is
pivotal of course it's also about having
more people who can
physically put the shots into the arms
of americans
and it's about ensuring we have places
that that can be done
i don't have anything for you on the
prioritization that's something of
course that our team is
working through and we want to ensure
that we are working closely with
governors across the country to
effectively do that
tell me your second question again i
know you have one after this the second
part of that question was just
uh will it be any federal assistance to
support states and reaching out to
seniors who may not have access to
you know internet or even phone to to
schedule these appointments that's been
a complaint that's emerged
a lot yeah it's a really important
question because
what we've discovered and what our team
has discovered is that
the further you get into vaccinating
americans the harder it becomes
there for a couple of reasons one is
have vaccine hesitancy which dr fauci
talked about
as an issue that was of great concern to
him and some other
health and medical experts and it's it's
more predominant in communities of color
but as you noted there is also an issue
with communicating with a range of
people in the public some in rural
communities
for different reasons but also seniors
and others who don't
who aren't picking up their phone and
looking at information on instagram
every day um and not
not receiving information in the same
way that young adults would be
so part of our effort is to uh use an
across the board a public communications
campaign an effort to meet people where
they are
and certainly thinking about how to
reach seniors doing it in a way where it
is
being done locally by trusted
authorities and trusted figures
locally we found to be a key a key
effective approach to that but we will
continue to be working on that and is
definitely one of the challenges that
we're facing
this question is from ross palumbo from
abc in south florida
he adds florida governor ron desantis
has blasted part of the president's
covet plan specifically saying
quote fema camps are not necessary in
florida
has or will the president be reaching
out to desantis
what is his reaction to comet like these
well uh the president is a pretty even
keeled guy
so i would say that he doesn't have much
of a reaction other than he wants to
ensure that the
vaccine is distributed um to people
across the country including
of course the millions of people living
in florida and i will note because we're
data first here facts first here
they've only distributed about 50
percent of the vaccines that they have
been given
in florida so um clearly they have a a
a good deal of the vaccine that supply
will need to continue to increase
as they are able to effectively reach
people across the state but part of the
challenge as we were just talking about
is not just having the supply
that's pivotal but also having
vaccinators and having vaccine
distribution places
and doing it in a way that's reaching
people where they are and meeting
local communities and the president's
going to be focused on that in a
bipartisan manner
regardless of what any uh elected
official may have to say
uh go ahead all the way in the back all
the way back hi
thanks jen um in an executive order that
the president signed last week
he also suspended a trump administrative
administration executive order
that was particularly aimed at keeping
foreign countries specifically china
from interfering in the u.s power grid
but he suspended that for 90 days in
that executive order last week given
what you said about china today
why did he do that especially related to
something so critical to our national
security of the power grid
i'll have to i think the president's
view on on our relationship with china
i uh tried to do my best to convey to
all of you i'll have to check on that
specific piece and
we'll circle back with you directly go
ahead um
thank you the um administration
said that uh the remaining mexico policy
from the prior administration
would not be uh enforced anymore but
there are thousands of people
who are stuck now as a result of that
policy
and the administration has not said what
you'll do with them
and how to process these migrants what
is the answer to that
in terms of migrants at the border well
yeah and
who are stuck as a result they're made
in mexico you know there are many
thousands of people
well i think there's a couple of steps
that we we're working to convey and
convey more effectively to people
directly living in
many of the countries who are who have
large populations uh
who are coming to the border one is that
this is not the right time to come
uh we have proposed a number of policies
um that we are working to implement
including a
uh pause on deportations as you know for
people who are in the united states
that is something the department of
homeland security would be
working to implement we've also proposed
an immigration bill something the
president
put forward on day one we've also
proposed funding to
help address the circumstances and the
uh challenging conditions that are on
the ground
in a number of these countries i'm
talking about those people who are in
limbo at the moment not discouraging new
people from coming
and not applying it to new people but
those people who were specifically
turned away by the trump administration
i i'd send you the department of
homeland security on that for a more
specific assessment for a second
question
i just wanted to press you a little
harder you said uh earlier that the
president had been speaking with members
of the senate
he wouldn't say who they were anything
about those conversations and because
they were private
i mean they were presumably discussing
the people's business
is that a matter you know why should
those be private why not
be more revealing of who the president
is speaking with
that is in the government well the i
what i said is that the president is
speaking with democrats and republicans
as are a number of senior officials from
the current white house and we'll
continue to do that
and what i meant was those conversations
getting their feedback about what they
think about bills and legislation
how they feel about the covet package
that the president put forward
where they have concerns where they have
agreement uh that some of those
conversations are private they can speak
publicly about their conversations of
course as
many of them have done but what i was
confirming is that he personally is
involved
and will continue to be involved in
moving this package forward
why not release the names of the people
who the president's speaking with to
negotiate on this bill i mean i know you
want to have more transparency in this
administration you've talked about it a
lot already
and why not make that a part of the
transparency effort
well again he's speaking with members of
both parties a number of them
uh would like to have those
conversations private as well a number
of them have also spoken publicly about
conversations they've had with the
administration so
and that perfectly is perfectly fine by
us uh go ahead and
ask uh on going back to clothing do you
know when
americans will be able to be widely
vaccinated
well of course we defer to our health
and medical experts as as you all know
and dr fauci spoke to this briefly last
week and i expected something that
our health and medical experts who will
be doing a briefing
later this week will be able to speak to
more specifically
we obviously have set out our bold goal
of 100 million vaccine
or 100 million shots in the arms of
americans in the first hundred days
we will build from there and we are
looking forward to building from there
uh but i don't have an assessment a new
assessment for you on
when a broad popular group of publishers
the previous administration said it
would be sort of mid-year they said that
regularly
uh you know our the cdc and other health
and medical experts have uh from our
team have given assessments uh
leaning towards the summer and fall but
i don't have a new assessment for you
from here but i'd encourage you to ask
them that and
that's why we're putting them out to
answer questions to all of you
jonathan go ahead uh the trump
administration in its final weeks rush
through a number of federal executions
uh has the president directed a
moratorium on capital punishment
uh the president's position on the death
penalty i think you're probably familiar
with others may not be he's opposed to
the death penalty i don't have anything
to preview for you in terms of
what steps he may take
um you said that these chronologists
briefings are going to start president
trump did not attend a lot of the
current or some of the chronographs
briefings at the end he did not attend a
lot of the current virus task force
briefings
is president biden going to attend those
task force meetings within the
group that's working on this he will be
briefed regularly i suspect far more
regularly than the past president was
briefed on covet and and the
developments and progress the team is
making
i wouldn't expect he attends every task
force meeting no but he
expects and requests regular briefings
from the team and i expect he'll get
them
okay go ahead if the whole point of
impeaching somebody
is basically to get rid of them and
trump is already gone
would president biden support maybe the
senate censuring him just so that
lawmakers can move on with the people's
business
yeah i really appreciate your creative
way of asking this question which has
come up a few times in here uh
the president in the senate for 36 years
as you all know
uh he is no longer in the senate and he
will leave it up to
members of the senate democrats and
republicans to determine how they will
hold the former president accountable
all right thank you i'm sorry i just
want to ask really
briefly on afghanistan if you guys
receive further troop reductions there
and what kind of numbers would we be
talking about
uh it's an excellent question we're on
day five so i don't have anything new
for you on
specifically uh afghanistan troop
reduction but
i'm hoping to get jake sullivan out to
the briefing room soon
uh to answer a lot of your questions on
a range of issues
thank you everyone thank you
all right one more i'm sorry about that
we don't want to leave you hanging we've
been very patient in the back
yeah we present for the uh the foreign
press group
i have two uh foreign policy issue one
on china and one on the uk
okay from china we just you just
mentioned about competition
and president biden's uh asia tsar
kurt campbell says he hopes for a stable
competition is that what the white house
is looking for
and you just mentioned about this
comprehensive strategy
when can we expect of that i appreciate
all of those questions i have
no i don't have any preview for you on
when we will have
more specifics on our strategy i've
tried to convey
overarching the president's overarching
approach um
but again this is a a a relationship
uh that uh we are going to be uh
conv communicating with and working with
partners and allies
on uh those are there are a number of
calls that will happen over the coming
weeks with key partners and allies i'm
sure this will be a topic of discussion
as well as democrats and republicans on
the hill and we are
going to approach it with patients and
on the uk
we know over the weekend president biden
had a phone call with
prime minister boris johnson and
mr johnson said they they talk about the
free trade
deal however from the white house read
out we don't
see that does the president support the
free trade deal with the uk i haven't
talked to him or
jake sullivan about that i'll venture to
do that and see if i can get more for
you on it
thanks everyone thank you thank you
thank you
thank you
i hope they'd already left